on a découvert que la torture était
pratiquée de manière industrielle aux
usbékistan il s'agissait de milliers de
cas chaque année
ce que j'ai aussi constaté à travers les
centaines de cas que j'ai pu vérifier
c'est que la torture était toujours
utilisée dans le même but celui de faire
avouer aux prisonniers qu'il connaissait
Ben Laden et qu'ils étaient membres
d'Al-Qaïda
[Musique]
le 11 septembre 2001 l'Amérique déclare
la guerre au terrorisme il y a les
champs de bataille connus
l'Afghanistan est à Liban puis l'Irak de
Saddam Hussein
mais loin des bombes une autre offensive
est déclenchée une guerre invisible
menée par les Américains chez nous en
Europe depuis 2005 des témoignages
mettent en cause la CIA pour des
opérations illégalement sur notre sol
enlèvement de citoyens européens
transfert par avion privé de la CIA
détention arbitraires dans des prisons
secrètes et tortues nous avons enquêté
sur cette guerre secrète en Europe
[Musique]
vote historique aujourd'hui au Parlement
européen pour la première fois depuis sa
création il lance une enquête sur les
activités secrètes de la CIA en Europe
46 députés issus d'une quinzaine de pays
européens sont désignés les apprentis
inspecteurs à l'assaut du plus puissant
service secret du monde alors tête le
président de la commission Carlos Coelho
46 ans ancien secrétaire d'État
portugais centre droit Sarah luthford
libéral britannique baronne de son état
55 ans et l'Italie incla audio Fava
socialiste sicilien fils d'un
journaliste tué il y a 20 ans pour ses
enquêtes sur la mafia
ces dernières années dans la lutte
contre le terrorisme
notre commission a eu pour but
d'enquêter sur ses abus et de comprendre
quelles sont les responsabilités des
pays de l'Union européenne
qui a décidé de ne rien voir qui de ne
rien comprendre et qui a décidé de
collaborer activement avec la CIA dans
ses abus
pendant 6 mois les parlementaires nous
ont laissé suivre leurs investigations
de mars à juillet 2006 nous avons vécu
de l'intérieur les rebondissements de
cette enquête hors norme
la première audition qui fait date dans
l'enquête de nos députés c'est en avril
2006 avec celle de ce citoyen allemand
d'origine libanaise Khaled El Masri il
accuse la CIA de l'avoir enlevé
illégalement en Europe et séquestrée
pendant 5 mois en Afghanistan c'est son
avocat qui raconte l'essentiel de cet
étrange histoire elle met en scène un
avion privé un enlèvement à la frontière
macédonienne et de mauvais traitements
ils l'ont amené à l'aéroport de stocker
on lui a fait passer un examen médical
dans une pièce à part on lui a bandait
les yeux on la ligoté il ne savait pas
ce qui lui arrivait
subitement plusieurs personnes ont
commencé à le frapper coup de pied coup
de poing de toute part
que c'est la première fois qu'il y a une
victime qu'il part dans une seule et
fonctionnelle comme les parlements
européens l'affaire elmasri a été révélé
trois mois plus tôt par la presse
américaine aujourd'hui il est trop
éprouvé pour affronter les micro-ondes
comprenez c'est une histoire très dur à
vivre pour lui et je veux éviter qu'il
ne craque à nouveau ça lui est déjà
arrivé pendant une interview
nous sommes donc à aller chez lui à
Houlme dans le sud de l'Allemagne
réfugiés politiques 38 ans marié père de
quatre enfants avant sa mésaventure à
l'aide elmasri vendait des voitures
d'occasion aujourd'hui il est au chômage
je suis originaire du Liban
je suis arrivé en Allemagne en 1985
et je suis naturalisé allemand depuis
son cauchemar débute en décembre 2003
confronté à des problèmes familiaux pour
souffler Khaled el Matri se paye un tour
d'Europe en bus Autriche
slovénie-croatie Bosnie Serbie tout va
bien le 31 décembre il arrive en
Macédoine c'est là que les ennuis
commencent lors d'un classique contrôle
douanier il est arrêté interrogé puis
immédiatement transféré dans un hôtel de
la capitale scopie
j'ai été longuement interrogé par des
Macédoniens
en civil mais armée
j'ai été gardé au secret
allongé sur un lit
même quand j'allais aux toilettes la
porte devait toujours rester ouverte il
ne me lâchait pas des yeux
durant les 23 jours de ma détention je
n'ai pu prendre qu'une seule douche et
même pendant cette douche il y avait
quelqu'un qui me regardait
la frappé
dans cette pièce il y avait un
ordinateur
au bout d'une semaine environ enfin je
me souviens plus exactement
ils ont décidé de l'allumer et ils se
sont mis à regarder des films porno et
d'autres choses que je ne pouvais pas
voir
après ces trois semaines de
séquestration l'affaire se complique
encore Khaled El Masri affirme avoir été
emmenée par des hommes cagoulés et vêtus
de noir il est jeté dans un avion civil
les yeux bandés ligotés à son siège
après 12 heures de voyage et une halte à
Bagdad il atterrit en Afghanistan à
Kaboul
[Musique]
j'ai la première nuit de ma captivité
des hommes cagoulés m'ont emmené dans
une salle d'interrogation
où il y avait d'autres hommes eux aussi
cagoulés qui attendaient
il y avait un traducteur arabe et un
médecin américain qui n'a pas dit un mot
le traducteur m'a dit qu'ils étaient
tous américains
dès cette première nuit on m'a fait
comprendre très clairement et dans un
pays où il n'y a pas de loi
on peut enterrer ou t'oublier pendant 20
ans personne ne sera ce que tu es devenu
aujourd'hui je ne sais toujours pas
pourquoi j'ai survécu parce que cette
raison n'était vraiment pas faite pour
des êtres humains
dans cette prison il dort à même le sol
on lui jette des restes de repas après 5
mois de détention au secret des agents
américains lui annoncent qu'ils se sont
trompés de personnes un avion privé le
ramène alors quelque part en Europe
lorsqu'ils m'ont relâché en pleine forêt
et de nuit je ne savais pas où aller
d'un geste de la main aux mains indiqué
un sentier
c'était un endroit complètement lugubre
plus loin
il y avait trois hommes en uniforme et
armé ils ont contrôlé mes papiers
d'identité et m'ont emmené dans une
cabane au dessus de la porte il y avait
un drapeau albanais
parvient finalement à rejoindre
l'Allemagne voici la première photo
prise au terme de sa mésaventure
il raconte son histoire à un avocat qui
fait éclater l'affaire huit mois plus
tard dans la presse américaine à ce
moment pour le gouvernement bouche
Khaled El Masri est un mythomane et en
Allemagne grande prudence on affirme ne
pas avoir été informé de sa disparition
une plainte est déposée le parquet de
Munich et saisie
nos députés européens décident
d'enquêter sur cette histoire un mois
après l'audition de Bruxelles direction
la Macédoine là-bas aussi les autorités
ont toujours ni à la version d'almasri
mais à la lecture des différentes
versions quelque chose ne colle pas
de relire tout ce que nous avons toutes
les déclarations et toutes les
dépositions officielles des
gouvernements allemands et Macédoniens
et je les compare avec ce que El Masri
nous a dit en commission
une chose est sûre c'est que sa version
est radicalement différente
il est clair que quelqu'un ne dit pas la
vérité dans cette histoire et notre
voyage en Macédoine va nous aider à
comprendre qui dit la vérité et qui ment
[Musique]
ancienne petite république yougoslave la
Macédoine est aujourd'hui candidate à
l'entrée dans l'Union européenne une
heure après l'atterrissage nos cinq
parlementaires mandatés par Bruxelles
ont rendez-vous avec le chef de l'État
en tant que président de la République
je vous assure que toutes les
institutions macédoniennes concernées
par cette affaire sont à votre entière
disposition pour vous aider à établir la
vérité
je souhaite que cet entretien que j'ai
le plaisir d'avoir avec vous soit un bon
point de départ pour votre visite et
votre travail en Macédoine
après les formules de politesse nous
sommes invités à quitter la salle
derrière cette porte le président répète
la version officielle après avoir été
interrogé à la frontière Khaled el
masria était autorisé à rentrer sur le
territoire macédonien pour y passer 23
jours de vacances
à la sortie nos députés sont sceptiques
il y a un trou de 23 jours c'est
impossible que cet homme ait disparu
il y a des choses que je ne comprends
pas si tu es au pouvoir et qu'on accuse
ton gouvernement de choses aussi graves
tu devrais tout faire pour apporter les
preuves de ton innocence
la position des Macédoniens est simple
l'histoire commence après ces 23 jours
lorsque les Américains récupèrent le
Masri pour eux ce n'est donc pas leurs
problèmes
c'est pas leur problème
le lendemain rendez-vous avec le
ministre de l'Intérieur lubomirailowski
l'homme chargé du dossier le
[Musique]
mastery de Pologne
nous ne pouvons pas assister à
l'entretien mais nous en avons récupéré
le script
la députée européenne affirme je suis
désolé mais pour nous il est clair
quelle Masri était détenue ici et qu'un
avion de la CIA a quitté scopie pour
Kaboul en passant par Bagdad le 24
janvier 2004
réplique du ministre nous avons
l'immatriculation de l'avion qui quitte
copié mais nous ne savons pas si c'est
un avion de la CIA
question du rapporteur le ciel de Bagdad
était fermé en cette période de guerre
comment expliquer vous que cet avion ait
pu voler de scopie à Bagdad
réponse du ministre on ne vérifie pas
les avions privés si vous savez ce qui
se cache derrière tout cela merci de me
le faire savoir
à la sortie face à la presse le langage
est beaucoup plus diplomatique
aujourd'hui nous avons rencontré la
commission d'enquête européenne
nous avons eu des échanges de vue
constructifs et j'espère que ce que nous
avons dit permettra d'élucider cette
affaire
je pense désormais que les rumeurs selon
lesquelles les services de police
Macédoniens sont impliqués dans cette
histoire vont pouvoir s'effacer
sa déclaration terminée nous avons
encore une petite question à lui poser
monsieur le ministre à l'intérieur de
l'hôtel scopski Mirac El Masri était-il
libre oui oui dans l'hôtel il était
libre et il a payé la note
oui enfin je suppose on ne l'aurait pas
laissé partir s'il n'avait pas payé sa
note
les parlementaires n'ont pour le moment
obtenu qu'une seule information mais
elle est de taille c'est le nom de
l'hôtel où elle Masri a passé ses
soi-disant vacances
c'est la première fois
dans l'hôtel donc cet hôtel
voici cet hôtel situé dans un quartier
résidentiel de la capitale à 300 mètres
de l'ambassade américaine pour le
visiter nos députés enquêteurs ont
préalablement appelé le directeur de
l'établissement avec qui ils ont
rendez-vous
est-ce que quelqu'un est au courant que
nous devions rencontrer le directeur
[Musique]
de la caméra si on veut discuter
vous pouvez couper la caméra le
directeur a disparu il serait subitement
parti en vacances malaise
une heure plus tard le réceptionniste
accepte finalement de faire la visite
arrivée au troisième étage chambre
numéro 11
c'est ici quelle master
première observation tout concorde la
chambre correspond en tout point à la
description faite par elmasri
jusqu'à l'ordinateur posé sur le bureau
c'est difficile d'imaginer qu'un chômeur
qui arrive d'Allemagne en bus avec très
peu d'argent en poche puisse passer 23
jours dans cette chambre pendant les
fêtes de fin d'année
il nous manque une partie de la vérité
qui l'a amené ici et qui l'a maintenu
ici
est-ce qu'on va voir les autres chambres
je crois pas que ce soit nécessaire
elles sont toutes pareilles les chambres
la seule chose qu'on pourrait faire
c'est de jeter un œil au registre de
l'hôtel
mais ils ne verront jamais ces registres
nos députés n'ont en fait pas le pouvoir
de saisir des documents seulement celui
d'interroger des témoins quand ils ne
sont pas partis en vacances
c'est normal que nous n'ayons rien
trouvé
le directeur de l'hôtel savait que nous
allions venir alors il s'est pris
quelques jours de vacances donc les
choses qu'on a entendu on le savait déjà
pour nous dire mon Dieu vous avez tout
découvert vous êtes ici dans un hôtel de
la CIA et non je ne m'y attendais pas
fin de leur visite les députés rentrent
à Bruxelles nous nous sommes restés à se
copier
deux jours plus tard retour à l'hôtel et
bonne surprise nous tombons nez à nez
avec le directeur
et vous venez de rentrer de vacances
c'était bien
pour la suite de l'interview le
directeur nous emmène dans la fameuse
chambre numéro 11 et pour montrer sa
bonne foi il nous propose de nous la
louer
voilà la prison dans laquelle El Masri a
été séquestrée
je ne crois pas vraiment que cette
chambre ressemble à une prison
combien ça coûte cette chambre pour une
nuit le prix normal est de 100 euros
qui n'a pas d'argent
c'est pas mon problème
il a payé cash
qu'il a payé casse je m'en souviens
vous souvenez de ça je m'en souviens en
tout cas je peux le voir d'après les
factures je peux voir la note pas
maintenant les factures qui ont plus de
2 ans on les garde pas ici mais si vous
restez jusqu'à demain pas de problème
donc demain c'est possible je la verrai
c'est possible
le lendemain le directeur de l'hôtel est
reparti en vacances nous ne verrons
jamais la facture mais désormais
locataire de cette chambre nous en
profitons pour faire parler l'ordinateur
là en quelques clics nous accédons à
l'historique de la machine la zone dans
laquelle sont mémorisés toutes les
dernières opérations faites sur un
ordinateur
devant nos yeux défilent alors la preuve
que cette chambre n'est pas une chambre
d'hôtel comme les autres
explication ici depuis 2001 toutes les
chambres sont équipées d'un ordinateur
connecté à Internet et mis gratuitement
au service des clients nous avons
consulté plusieurs ordinateurs de cet
hôtel leurs historiques font apparaître
des connexions quotidiennes et des
centaines de pages consultées
au troisième étage de l'hôtel scopski
Mirac dans la chambre numéro 11 c'est
très différent l'ordinateur n'a été
allumé que trois fois entre 2003 et 2006
parmi ces trois dates figure celle du 8
janvier 2004
le 8e jour de la séquestration présumée
de ralla SRI
souvenez-vous à quel moment ils ont
allumé l'ordinateur de la chambre
peut-être un peu plus
notre enquête en Macédoine confirme les
affirmations de Khaled elmasri reste à
comprendre pourquoi il a été enlevé
retour en Allemagne nous retrouvons
Khaled El Masri il nous emmène cette
fois-ci à la mosquée qu'il fréquentait
une fois par semaine avant son
arrestation elle est aujourd'hui fermée
car jugée trop radical à l'époque elle
était placée sous la surveillance des
services secrets allemands
[Musique]
en Macédoine
et ensuite en Afghanistan concerné
principalement cette mosquée
et les gens qui la fréquenté
dans cette mosquée Khaled El Masri
rencontre un militant islamiste radical
Reda Sayam suspecté d'avoir financé les
attentats de Bali en 2003
comment l'avez-vous rencontré Reda
Saiyan
j'ai connu Reda Sayam ici dans cette
mosquée dès mon arrivée en Allemagne
à l'époque nous étions tous les deux à
la recherche d'un appartement
ni le procureur ni la police ne le
considère comme quelqu'un de proche du
terrorisme
il venait juste prier dans cette mosquée
la seule dans la région rien de plus
rien de moins
aucun doute pour l'avocat les Allemands
ont prévenu les Macédoniens de l'arrivée
de son client
savaient parfaitement qu'une des
personnes qui venaient prier de temps en
temps ici aller faire un voyage en bus
jusqu'en Macédoine
on a appris que dans l'ordinateur des
douaniers Macédoniens il y avait une
information concernant l'arrivée de
Khaled El Masri
lors de son passage à la frontière
l'ordinateur a donc donné l'alerte sur
la base d'information envoyée par les
Allemands donc il y a forcément eu un
contact direct entre les Allemands et
les Macédoniens
les autorités allemandes ont-elles
livrées l'un de leurs ressortissants à
la CIA nous avons rendez-vous avec le
ministre de l'Intérieur de l'époque
otoshini il accepte de nous recevoir
mais quand il comprend que nous
souhaitons évoquer l'affaire El Masri il
refuse de démarrer l'interview et nous
demande de quitter la pièce
non non non désolé nous devons arrêter
comprenez c'est un cas sensible pour moi
non comprenez-moi bien je pourrais avoir
des ennuis
au printemps 2006 le parlement allemand
a décidé lui aussi d'enquêter sur
l'affaire El Masri
d'activités illégales qui peuvent se
révéler dangereuses
alors il appartient à la police
allemande de suivre l'affaire
on ne peut pas admettre sans son
inquiéter qu'un service secret étranger
agit à notre insulte
1er juin 2006 le BND les services
secrets allemands ont reconnu dans un
communiqué qu'un de leurs agents étaient
au courant de l'enlèvement d'El Masri
depuis le début mais selon ce communiqué
l'agent secret en poste à Skopje aurait
oublié de prévenir sa hiérarchie
ne pouvant être sûr de cette information
l'agent a préféré ne pas la transmettre
nous ferons le nécessaire pour que ce
genre de panne d'information ne se
reproduise plus au sein de nos services
avait de la faire nous l'ignorons pour
l'instant mais on finira par la prendre
c'est que que les autorités allemandes
étaient au courant ou non de toute façon
il faudra bien qu'elle réorganise la
boutique il n'est pas possible qu'un
agent des services secrets qui reçoit
une information pareille ne la
transmettent pas à ses autorités
les premiers travaux de l'enquête des
députés mettent déjà à mal la version
officielle allemande plusieurs agents
des services secrets doivent être
prochainement entendus dans le cadre de
cette enquête enlevez puis séquestrer en
Europe transférer également un Kaboul
maltraité pendant 5 mois par des agents
américains pour se reconstruire Khaled
elmasri attend toujours que les
autorités allemandes et américaines
reconnaissent enfin son histoire
à Bruxelles les euros députés viennent
d'obtenir un document essentiel pour
comprendre les transferts illégaux de
détenus
la liste des plans de vols secrets des
avions de la CIA un document
confidentiel fourni par eurocontrôle
l'organisme chargé de surveiller le ciel
européen j'ai vérifié les documents de
recontrôles
et on y trouve bien l'avion d'El Masri
il est parti de skier pour aller vers
Caboul en passant par Bagdad
ils ont pu suivre la trace du vol
j'ai vu le numéro de vol la date et les
horaires
tout correspond avec ce que nous a dit
El Masri
comment pouvait-il connaître l'existence
de ce vol
ce n'est pas un avion de ligne et
personne n'a accès à ses documents
donc nous pouvons dire que son histoire
est bien réelle
ces plans de vol sont un tournant dans
l'enquête des parlementaires qui
convoquent une conférence de presse
nous pouvons affirmer qu'au cours des
dernières années dans l'espace aérien et
dans les aéroports des pays membres
associés ou candidats à l'Union
européenne il y a eu plus de 1000 vols
effectués par des avions de la
ciavel en Pologne 59 au Portugal 210 en
Angleterre 430 en Allemagne en France
les enquêteurs n'ont pointé que 6 vols
litigieux sur lesquels la justice en
quête sur ces 1000 vols seule une
dizaine aurait servi à transférer
illégalement des prisonniers de la CIA
et pour ces opérations clandestine on
retrouve les mêmes avions ce Boeing
immatriculé n313p et au moins ces trois
golf stream
avec ses avions a été mise en place un
gigantesque réseau de vols secrets des
rotations régulières effectuées entre
Washington et Kaboul avec des escales à
travers toute l'Europe
l'un des aéroports les plus suspects ces
shimani en Pologne terminus de plusieurs
de ses vols
[Musique]
si tu es au nord du pays nous nous y
sommes rendus
c'est un ancien aéroport international
qui a vu atterrir et Castro mais qui est
aujourd'hui quasiment désaffecté
c'est le directeur qui nous reçoit
c'est ici le fameux aéroport
oui c'est le plus connu au monde
l'aéroport est doté d'une piste longue
de 2 km conçu pour accueillir des gros
porteurs en 2003 des avions civils à
prêté par la CIA aurait atterri ici à
deux reprises le gouvernement polonais a
pour l'instant toujours nié mais le
directeur est beaucoup moins catégorique
oui je le n'irai pas je n'étais pas là à
cette époque je me suis directeur que
depuis 2004
mais c'est une histoire connue ici je
vous confirme que ces avions
atterrissaient bien ici
trois ans si ces fleurs ont remplacé les
avions sur le tarmac de l'aéroport
international de shimani le souvenir des
vols secrets de la CIA lui n'a pas
disparu
c'est ici que la piste commence ce
Boeing est venu de là-bas et il s'est
arrêté ici il n'a pas circulé il s'est
juste arrêté ici
[Musique]
il a atterri puis il est reparti ils
sont juste venus pour regarder les
cigognes en fait
à une dizaine de kilomètres de là nous
avons retrouvé une ancienne employée de
l'aéroport lorsque les avions de la CIA
se sont posés à chimani elle était
présente ce dont elle fut témoin alors
ne ressemble pas vraiment à une visite
pour admirer les cigognes craignant pour
sa sécurité elle accepte de témoigner à
visage caché à l'époque où je
travaillais à l'aéroport des avions type
Golf stream et Boeing ont atterri
hashimani
ces avions avaient un comportement
étrange
de stationnement habituel
il s'arrêtait toujours sur la piste à
une grande distance du terminal
ça il se positionnait pour que leur
porte s'ouvre toujours en direction de
la forêt afin que l'on ne puisse pas
voir qui montait ou descendait de ses
avions
et cet étrange car normalement il n'y a
jamais d'officier de police présents
lors des opérations internationales
et pour l'aéroport la CIA était un très
bon client
le paiement pour l'opération
d'atterrissage et les services de
l'aéroport ont été fait en cash
la plupart du temps le lendemain
les factures portaient le nom de société
américaines
différentes
et les paiements étaient toujours fait
en cash
factures car ce sont des sommes beaucoup
plus élevées que la normale pour ce type
d'avion
il y avait toujours des officiers de la
police des frontières qui s'approchaient
des avions on les voyait parler avec le
capitaine
et puis lorsqu'il s'en allait des mini
vannes aux vitres fumées qui attendaient
en bordure de forêt venait jusqu'aux
avions
c'était les mini vannes de la base qui
écoutait une base des services secrets
polonais
il existe effectivement une base des
services secrets à une dizaine de
kilomètres de cet aéroport à côté de ce
lac en pleine forêt voici ses antennes
les mini vannes dont se souvient notre
employé ont-ils permis de transférer des
détenus de la CIA
cette base est découpée en secteurs bien
protégés que l'on peut apercevoir sur
cette photo satellite l'un de ces
secteurs est exclusivement gérée par les
Américains il pourrait abriter une
prison secrète de la CIA
Diana price journaliste vedette du
Washington Post elle a été récompensée
pour son enquête sur ses prisons
secrètes son contact un agent des
services américains la convaincu de leur
existence en Europe
dans les pays d'Europe de l'Est tous ces
prisons ont existé bien sûr les
gouvernements savaient ils ont autorisé
leur installation
à chaque fois il y a eu des accords pour
que cela reste secret c'est la raison
pour laquelle la Commission d'enquête du
Parlement européen fait un travail
impossible les gouvernements concernés
ne leur diront pas la vérité
à l'appel d'Amnesty International manif
devant l'ambassade américaine
pas près de vous lâcher
une poignée de militante des droits de
l'homme est venue dénoncer les vols
secrets de la CIA
parmi eux la baronne luthford en colère
jusqu'à présent aucun ministre des
gouvernements européens a répondu
présent aux demandes d'audition de sa
commission d'enquête
il doit y avoir une enquête sur ses
actions illégales pour lesquelles nous
avons des preuves
il faut inverser les choses c'est au
gouvernement de trouver la vérité et de
nous la dire
nous avons besoin de votre soutien pour
les obliger à nous donner ses réponses
je suis convaincu qu'on trouvera la
vérité elle sera pénible mais il n'y a
qu'elle qui nous permet de rétablir
notre autorité morale
cela veut dire de retrouver la sécurité
dans ce monde car nous ne sommes pas
plus en sécurité en brisant les droits
de l'homme au contraire cela nous met en
danger la liberté fait partie de la
sécurité ils ne sont pas opposés
ici en Angleterre un homme estime lui
aussi que la lutte antiterroriste telle
qu'elle se pratique aujourd'hui mais nos
démocraties en danger Craig Murray 48
ans dont 21 passés au service de Sa
Majesté comme diplomate son dernier
poste ambassadeur en Ouzbékistan
on a découvert que la torture était
pratiquée de manière industrielle au
newsbékistan il s'agissait de milliers
de cas chaque année
ce que j'ai aussi constaté à travers les
centaines de cas que j'ai pu vérifier
c'est que la torture était toujours
utilisée dans le même but celui de faire
avouer au prisonniers qu'il connaissait
Ben Laden et qu'ils étaient membres
d'Al-Qaïda
concret Murray apprend que ces
informations obtenues sous la torture
sont transmises aux autorités anglaises
il alerte son supérieur le ministre des
Affaires étrangères Jacques straw
extrait du message que Craig Murray
envoie son ministre
les Américains nous ont transmis les
informations obtenues sous la torture
par les services secrets ouzbek cela est
moralement et légalement condamnable
j'ai constaté des centaines de cas et je
n'en ai quasiment vu aucun pour lequel
la torture telle qu'elle est définie par
la Convention des Nations Unies
n'étaient employés
[Musique]
l'ambassadeur termine en citant
l'article 2 de la Convention des Nations
Unies signées aussi bien par
l'Angleterre que par les États-Unis
que l'on soit en guerre ou en menace de
guerre qu'il y ait des risques de guerre
civile ou tout autre forme de menaces
rien de tout cela ne peut être évoqué
pour justifier le recours à la torture
aucune réponse officielle de son
ministre mais un entretien informel avec
l'un de ses adjoints lui révèle que le
gouvernement anglais assume
Michael wood m'a dit que ce n'était
effectivement pas légal pour nous
d'obtenir des informations sous la
torture
légalement à condition que quelqu'un
d'autre le face à notre place et sans
que nous l'ayons demandé
ent leurs informations
on m'a dit directement qu'à cause de cet
accord les Anglais étaient obligés
d'avoir la même politique que les
Américains sur la torture
dans cette guerre contre la terreur la
torture devient légitime
pour Craig Murray aucun doute vol secret
et torture sont liés c'est ce qu'il est
allé dire devant la Commission du
Parlement européen à Bruxelles
après ces déclarations il a été licencié
son gouvernement a lancé 18 procédures
contre lui pour entre autres alcoolisme
aggravé trafic de devises et déviances
sexuelles des accusations infondées
balayées en quelques semaines par une
enquête judiciaire pourtant Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur point désormais au chômage
carrière brisée
les responsables américains ont refusé
de venir témoigner à Bruxelles 15
parlementaires se rendent donc à
Washington nos députés veulent
interroger ceux qui ont pensé le
programme d'enlèvement en Europe
l'administration bouche et l'état-major
de la CIA dans le bus on retrouve le
Portugais Carlos Coelho président de la
commission la baronne butford et
l'italien Claudio Fava
comme je le dis depuis le début c'est
très important pour nous de rencontrer
l'autre partie dans cette histoire
on va entendre ce que l'administration
américaine et les membres du Congrès
vont nous dire à propos de ses avions
cocktail de bienvenue sans les
Américains pour l'instant c'est
l'ambassadeur de la Commission
européenne à Washington John Button qui
régale il leur souhaite bien du courage
[Musique]
sincèrement les problèmes abordés dans
ce cas sont extrêmement difficiles et
très sensibles les Américains ne
plaisent pas avec leur sécurité
les euros députés à l'assaut de la
mairie l'une des plus optimistes c'est
la baronne luth Ford ici elle se sent
presque en croisade
mon espoir
c'est d'aider les Américains à
comprendre
que cette politique est inefficace pour
eux
le Parlement européen qui représente les
peuples d'Europe enquêtes sur une
affaire qui implique directement des
gouvernements européens ce qui n'a
jamais été fait
de mon point de vue le fait d'être ici
est déjà un bon résultat
car nous n'avons pas obtenu des
gouvernements européens les mêmes
attentions que celles que nous avons
obtenu des Américains
le surlendemain quieza et ses amis ont
un premier rendez-vous avec les
autorités américaines le tour opérateur
nous a prévu une petite visite du
Congrès on nous a calé et un rendez-vous
avec un parlementaire on va bien voir ce
qu'il a à nous dire
c'est au Sénat que les parlementaires
doivent rencontrer Robert Wexler et lui
démocrate de Floride problème le
sénateur n'est pas là
où il est
avec le ministre des Affaires étrangères
jordanienne mais il va arriver dans une
seconde on est en train de lui dire de
se dépêcher là mais il va venir
en ce moment on a trois rendez-vous en
même temps
20 minutes plus tard Robert Wexler enfin
c'est un opposant résolu à bouche les
parlementaires font donc de sérieux
espoirs bonjour enchanté bonjour C'est
rald Ford je suis la vice-présidente
c'est l'un des rares hommes politiques
américains qui admettent ici que les
vols secrets en Europe ont bien existé
je tiens à vous remercier pour le temps
que vous nous consacrez
nous avons demandé à plusieurs membres
du Congrès de nous rencontrer
malheureusement ils n'ont pas eu le
temps
ou peut-être pas eu l'envie de le faire
nous souhaitons donc vraiment vous
remercier
la réunion se tiendra à
de retour dans le bus la commission
d'enquête à vous le rendez-vous avec le
sénateur Wexler les aisses
à faire un choix entre
l'anti-américanisme primaire des
Européens et être derrière bouche je
choisirais bouche à 100% même si je ne
suis pas 100% d'accord avec lui
tu dis n'importe quoi nous ne faisons
pas de l'anti-américanisme primaire je
suis une libérale de droite je ne suis
en aucun cas une anti-américaine
et toi tu te prétends être un Européen
non je suis un Britannique et je pensais
que toi aussi tu fais partie de l'Europe
non pas du tout moi je suis anglais je
viens du Nil c'est un continent à part
de toute façon sur quel continent tu vis
sur
quelle plaque le lendemain retour à
l'annexe du Sénat rendez-vous avec un
autre élu démocrate edmarky
arrivé dans la salle mais mauvaise
surprise elle est déjà occupée
bonjour nous sommes du Parlement
européen nous avions rendez-vous avec
EDM Market
vous attendiez quelqu'un d'autre
peut-être
bonjour enchanté
en fait ici on attend une commission
pour une réunion sur le Nigéria en tout
cas c'est ce qu'on nous a dit
maintenant
nos députés européens seront finalement
reçus par le sénateur dans une autre
salle
edmarkin n'a que 10 minutes à leur
consacré devant eux il évoque une
arrestation illégale de la
Ciara qui est un citoyen canadien a été
arrêté à l'aéroport de JFK de New York
il a été transporté en Syrie par la CIA
où il a été torturé
nous n'avons jamais trouvé de preuves
qui le lie à une activité terroriste
aujourd'hui il a pu rentrer chez lui
le sénateur démocrate a tenté de faire
passer une loi aux États-Unis contre ses
enlèvements mais il n'a trouvé aucun
soutien au Parlement sa loi n'est jamais
passée
les députés ont voulu rencontrer les
dirigeants de la CIA refus c'est
finalement un ancien directeur de
l'agence jamesley qui s'y colle patron
de 93 à 95 aujourd'hui il est consultant
proche de l'administration bouche
monsieur le Président en réalité je n'ai
rien à vous dire
vous m'avez invité pour parler d'un
sujet qui n'a jamais été abordé quand je
dirigeais la
ciao et en plus je n'ai eu aucune
information sur cette question
si vous le souhaitez
mais je vous préviens ça risque d'être
court et surtout à s'ennuyeux
son audition vire à la mauvaise blague
jamesley ne répondra à aucune question
des parlementaires
nous avons
appris l'utilisation de nos comme les
grands changent
la mission des euros députés sans bourbe
pas de réponse à leurs questions et
aucun écho à leur venue les médias
américains boudent leur visite alors on
se console avec une photo souvenir un
peu crispante
dernier espoir avec le rendez-vous le
plus important pour les enquêteurs
européens direction le département
d'État le ministère des Affaires
étrangères américains
la secrétaire d'État candauliste à Rice
a bien sûr décliné l'invitation ils vont
être reçus par un conseiller juridique
John Bellinger
le numéro 3 du Département d'État
vous avez la dernière fois que je suis
venu ici c'était il y a 5 ans et
l'administration américaine avait annulé
tous les rendez-vous on a fait plein de
déclarations désagréables aujourd'hui
c'est différent quelqu'un nous reçoit
alors on est content
pendant l'entretien on installe le tapis
rouge mais il n'est pas là pour les
députés européens une délégation
japonaise est attendue
les enquêteurs eux sortent par la petite
porte l'entretien s'est mal passé
alors c'était comment la rencontre
et bien la réunion a commencé par
par plusieurs menaces
ils nous ont expliqué clairement que
nous n'avions pas la légitimité
d'enquêter sur le gouvernement américain
et que les États-Unis n'étaient pas du
tout disposés à nous laisser travailler
ici
en bloc le fait de violer les lois
le fait d'envoyer des gens dans des pays
où la torture est pratiquée
je suis content car ils ont été
embarrassés à plusieurs reprises et je
suis content car j'ai vu leurs
difficultés à répondre précisément à nos
questions
quatre jours d'enquête et aucun élément
nouveau Washington continue de nier il
n'y a aucune violation de la
souveraineté européenne
mais rebondissements de retour dans leur
bureau de la Commission européenne à
Washington il trouve un fax un énorme
scandale est en train d'exploser à Rome
l'affaire va éclater dans le prochain
numéro de l'expression pour la première
fois on apprend qu'un gendarme italien
avoue avoir pris par Rocky de napping
d'un certain Abou Omar mais c'est
le chef des services secrets italiens le
général Polaris nous avait pourtant
assuré que les autorités italiennes
n'étaient au courant de rien
nous avons la preuve que la police
italienne et les services secrets ont
pris part à cette
opérations secrets nous a menti Polaris
nous a menti
Nicolas Polaris le voici
vous connaissiez monsieur abo Omar
c'était en mars 2006 le chef des
services secrets italiens était alors
auditionné à Bruxelles au tout début de
la commission d'enquête
l'affaire dont il doit parler concerne
l'enlèvement à Milan de Abou Omar anima
égyptien réfugié politique en Italie
l'histoire qui déstabilise aujourd'hui
les tailles italien et rocambolesque
elle commence ici en 2003 derrière ce
garage
une mosquée intéresse la justice
italienne des islamistes radicaux ils
sont repérés et placés sous la
surveillance de la police
au palais de justice de Milan le juge
italien chargé du dossier à l'époque ses
Guido Salvini la taille
en 2003 nous avons découvert une cellule
qui était suspectée de planifier les
attaques terroristes en Italie et il
réclausato et celui qui était chargé du
recrutement pour cette cellule était à
bout Omar l'imam d'une importante
mosquée de Milan
en train de surveiller Abou Omar ainsi
que la mosquée dans laquelle il
recrutait ses militants il a disparu
dans une rue de Milan
nous sommes rue Guerzoni à Milan c'est
là au numéro 34 qui a eu lieu
l'enlèvement d'Abou Omar il sortait de
chez lui il a dit à sa femme qu'il
allait se rendre à la mosquée
à causé une camionnette blanche s'est
approchée avec à l'intérieur au moins
trois hommes habillés à l'occidental
quelqu'un est descendu de la camionnette
et lui a demandé ses papiers dans un
Italien parfait
donné ses papiers et c'est à cet instant
qu'on lui a pulvérisé un produit sur le
visage
abomar est jeté dans la camionnette il
disparaît il refait surface quelques
heures plus tard en Égypte dans une
prison où il est détenu pour
appartenance à une mouvance terroriste
pour l'instant aucun procès n'est prévu
pour faire la lumière sur cette
enlèvement un procureur italien a été
nommé en 2005
lui aussi a témoigné devant la
commission d'enquête européenne il
s'agit du numéro 1 de la lutte
antiterroriste en Italie Armando Spataro
son témoignage est accablant il affirme
que c'est la CIA qui a bien enlevé Abou
Omar en plein milieu
à l'aide d'un diaporama Spataro dévoile
les visages et les noms des agents
américains qui ont participé à
l'opération
je peux maintenant vous présenter les
agents qui ont pris part à l'enlèvement
nous avons retrouvé des copies de leurs
papiers d'identité dans un hôtel
je les ai reproduits dans l'état où ils
ont été trouvés
certaines photos ne sont pas très
lisibles
d'autres par contre comme cette dernière
notamment est particulièrement claire
celle-ci également
mais il y a d'autres personnes
poursuivies en plus de celles dont nous
avons vu les photos
voici rapidement leur nom
parmi eux le numéro 17 Lady roberthe qui
est connu par les autorités italiennes
pour être le responsable de la CIA à
Milan
identification des téléphones portables
des agents de la CIA reconstitution de
leur déplacement le jour de l'enlèvement
devant les parlementaires pendant une
heure les preuves se succèdent et la
conclusion du magistrat et sans appel
je finis en affirmant que le séquestre
d'Abou Omar est un grave délit pour la
liberté des personnes et contre la
souveraineté italienne
mais cela a surtout porté un préjudice
grave à la lutte contre le terrorisme
car la police était en train de faire
une enquête approfondie sur Abou homard
on peut raisonnablement affirmer que
s'il n'avait pas été enlevé les enquêtes
de la police auraient menées à son
arrestation
il serait aujourd'hui jugé en Italie ce
qui aurait pu permettre l'identification
de ses complices
Armando Spataro a demandé l'extradition
de ses 25 agents de la CIA mais le
ministre italien de la justice s'y est
toujours opposé Roberto Castelli n'est
plus en poste aujourd'hui mais il assume
Yolo
donne l'image d'un pays où les
terroristes se promènent en liberté mais
je ne veux pas que mon pays donne
l'image d'un pays qui pratique la chasse
aux chasseurs de terroristes notre
peuple ne comprendrait pas en Italie
avant tout on se doit de combattre les
terroristes
mai 2006 l'affaire rebondi l'espresso un
hebdomadaire italien recueille les
confidences d'un carabinier nom de code
Ludwig l'homme avoue avoir donné un coup
de main aux agents de la CIA c'est lui
qui aurait interpellé Abou Omar en lui
demandant ses papiers au moment de son
enlèvement
extrait de l'article
[Musique]
le carabinier nous a dit qu'il n'y avait
pas que des agents de la CIA au moment
de l'opération plusieurs militaires
italiens ont participé à cet enlèvement
c'est le plus gros revers pour le
gouvernement Berlusconi qui nie depuis
trois ans la participation d'italien au
sein du commando qui a enlevé à boismard
accusé le gouvernement Berlusconi
continue de nier et ce sont les services
secrets qui trinquent le numéro 2 du
6000 et services secrets italiens
marquentini est arrêté et placé en
détention provisoire son supérieur
Nicolo polary celui qui avait été
auditionné à Bruxelles contre-attaque il
met en cause l'un des bras droit de
Berlusconi
dernier rebondissement tragique à Naples
un témoin clef disparaît eastigation
vers le suicide en ce qui concerne la
mort d'Adamo Bové le responsable de la
sécurité des télécoms italiens qui s'est
jeté d'un pont du périphérique de Naples
le nom de Beauvais était apparu dans
l'enquête délicate de l'enlèvement
d'Abou Omar
c'est lui qui avait aidé le procureur
Spataro dans son enquête en lui livrant
les écoutes téléphoniques qui ont permis
d'identifier les agents de la CIA au
moment où l'affaire s'emballe adamobové
fait une chute de 30 m du haut de ce
pont la police évoque pour l'instant un
suicide une enquête a été ouverte
l'enlèvement d'Abou Omar la détention de
Khaled El Masri la découverte de
l'aéroport polonais de shimani en six
mois d’enquête nos députés ont acquis la
conviction que certains pays européens
ont coopérer étroitement et en toute
illégalité avec la CIA
une première partie de mission accomplie
pour nos euros députés
nous avons découvert de nombreux
mensonges sur les relations entre les
gouvernements européens et la CIA
nous avons pu donner la parole à
certaines victimes elles ont été
entendues pour la première fois
et je crois que malgré toutes les
difficultés que nous avons rencontrées
depuis le début nous avons découvert de
nombreux faits et avancer vers la vérité
dans ce sens est un succès mais on va
surtout faire en sorte que ce qui s'est
passé ne se reproduisent
Claudio Fava et ses collègues ont obtenu
du Parlement la prolongation de leur
mandat pour une durée de 6 mois
désormais nos députés espèrent entendre
les principaux responsables politiques
des pays concernés l'Italie la
Grande-Bretagne la Pologne et nouvelle
très encourageante le 6 septembre
dernier pour la première fois George
bouge reconnaissait l'existence de
prison secrète de la CIA hors du sol
américain